[MUSIC PLAYING]
HUIJE LIN: Hello, everyone.
Nice to see you again.
I'm Huije Lin from NetEase.
Today I want to talk about
some things, applications,
and hardwares we have built
and created with Devlight.
And I have mentioned
yesterday, NetEase Youdao
is the leading company
in online education.
We have created a lot of popular
applications and hardwares
in China.
We are the leading
online education brand,
with the most users in China.
We have about over 800
million users in total,
and we also have 22
million daily active users.
And we also provide the Youdao
online course applications,
which has over 20 million
course attendances in a year.
And in the past
years, we have created
a lot of popular
applications in China.
We have the first leading
dictionary application
in China, which is
the Youdao dictionary.
We also have the most popular
translation application, which
is Dear Translate in China.
And we also have the most
popular dictionary and language
learning application in
India, which is U-Dictionary.
And we also have many
other applications
that are very popular in China.
For example, we have the
Youdao cost application,
and the reading
applications, and also
the applications for
practice our English.
And beyond that we
also have provided
many services and their
own device abilities
to our partners.
We have served over 40,000
developers in our Youdao AI
platform.
We provide many
useful abilities based
on our own developed
neuromachine translation,
the OCR, the ARU, and ASR, TTS,
so many fundamental abilities
are surrounded by always
the language scenarios.
And it will also
provide many solutions
related to the language
learning and education.
We have served many
partners in China.
And we are working
with our partners
to optimize our abilities
to provide better
services to the end users.
And as I have
mentioned yesterday,
we also have built
several applications
and useful functions
ways the Devlight.
For example, we have
built the word scanning
and look-up functions
with Devlight
in the dictionaries application.
And we also have created
some photo translation and AR
solutions with Devlight.
And here there is a
video that I can show you
how we do the AR translation.
You can scan the word, the text,
around you with your camera.
And it will translate the word
in real time with your camera
and by the OCR and
the translation.
So this is the first AR
translation in China.
And beyond applications, we also
have created some hardwares.
For example, we have created
the Youdao Translator King,
which is a translator machine.
It is [INAUDIBLE] Chinese to
English, Korean and Japanese,
offline speech translation,
and in reverse, of course.
And it will also provide
over 40 languages
online speed translation.
And it also supports online
and offline photo translation.
And we have done the
offline translation
to be a translation, and the
photo translation was Devlight.
And also, here is a video.
Then I can show
you how this works.
This is a man that is speaking
Chinese, and with device--
something about
booking a flight--
SPEAKER: Hello.
I have booked flight--
HUIJE LIN: --and it will
translate into English.
SPEAKER: --to New
York on September 29.
Now I want to change
to 1:00 PM on the 28th,
and I want to upgrade
the economy class-
HUIJE LIN: You can see the
translation is pretty good.
And beyond the
applications, we have also
created many
applications for students
for education and learning.
For example, we have created
a document-scan application
that you can scan your
document or your homework
with your camera, and it will
turn the text into the note
so you can store
your paper homework.
And we also have created
an intelligent homework
autochecking application
which is Youdao homework.
You can use your camera
to scan your homework
and it checks your
handwriting answers and checks
if it is right or wrong.
So the green is true.
It is right, and the red
color, it is the wrong answer.
And we also have
provided some speech
interaction applications.
So you can use this
app-- for example,
you can ask the app
what does tennis mean,
how to say tennis or
something like that.
It will look up the English
dictionary for the tennis--
for other words
and translations.
And we also have created
the handwritten character
recognition.
And then students can
write the characters
in Chinese or in English.
And we also have created
many other hardwares.
For example, we have the
Youdao dictionary pen.
You can use this pen to
scan the words on the paper,
and it will recognize words and
look up it in the dictionary.
It is very convenient.
And we also have
a Youdao note pen.
You can write characters
with this pen,
and it will record your
track into the cloud note.
And we also have homework pad.
You can do your
homework on the pad,
and it will recognize the
handwritten characters
and it does the
homework checking.
And we have talked about many
applications and hardware
we have built and created.
And we all know that
in the education
scenario, many
students in school,
they are limited
to the internet.
So we many offline on-device
inference for them.
So there are many
challenges here--
for example, the limited
power and limited computation
resource.
So we choose the TF Lite
to accelerate the Youdao's
on-device AI inference.
It is very easy to use,
and it is very efficient.
And as last, this is
our vision and mission,
which is to use technology and
AI to make people communicate,
study, and work much
more efficiently.
That's all my sharing.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]